I feel like not a lot of guys realize this
but being a SIMP is probably one of the hardest things you can do as a man
being a loving
devoted partner
taking her out to dinner
opening her door
getting her flowers
once you do all that
she's gonna run to all of her friends and brag about you
and she tells all of her friends about you
they're gonna think of you as a hero and think ugh
wish I had a guy like that
that's what I want
I think of you as the ideal man
gonna seem really cool to them
and on the opposite spectrum
the anti sip behaviours
the view of thinking ugh
I'm not gonna call her back
I'm not gonna buy her flowers
she's never bought me flowers
why do I need to get her flowers
that type of behaviour
she's gonna go and tell her friends about it
and you know what they're gonna say
they're gonna be like ugh
I'm so sorry babe
you're gonna find the right one eventually
not only that
when they see you
they're gonna be like Ew gross
he doesn't know how to treat a woman
this goes both ways
if you're a good girlfriend
good partner
your guy is gonna run to his friends and brag about you
if you're controlling
crazy annoying partner
he's gonna run to his friends and complain about you
don't you wanna be the girl that all of his friends are like
well you got a good one
like the envy of everybody
that's how power couples are made
only people who look down on simping are the same people who can't find a loving
devoted partner
so don't forget that simping is simply in